hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress under our game
Paul Charles Murphy against Louis
Paulson and this is Game five after four
games Murphy is in the lead but only by
a margin of one point as the second game
was drawn and a third game went the
Polson so in Game four
Murphy again won a game and not an easy
game but he did win it and now we're at
Game five so without further ado let's
check it out morphia again with the
white pieces and a lot of you have been
asking me how how come Murphy again has
the black piece how come Murphy again
has the white pieces
well it seems in those days you had like
white and then you were black two times
and then why two times it wasn't like
back and forth like today avi I mean III
don't really have like the internment
regulations and you were written how how
they went about this but it does seem so
but okay morphe again with white opens
again with efore and Paulson again with
the Sicilian we have a night of 3e 6d
for end characters like in the previous
game night captures Bishop to c5 and now
in the previous game Murphy decided for
Bishop to e3 but here he goes for the
modern Knights the b3 attacking the
bishop bishop back to be six now and
Knight to c3 continuing development we
have Knight the c6 by Paulsen and Bishop
the f4 now again morphe wants the pile
up under week d6 square maybe night the
be far will be an idea and should hinder
blacks development and here 90 G to e7
is a move that that's even played today
although very rarely would black go for
such such an opening but in those days
he five by Paulson and it's important to
say that this position after move seven
has never been reached again and for
good reasons more if he goes back now
there are really a lot of weaknesses you
no longer have the e6 pawn here to
support your d5 advancement and it will
be extremely difficult to execute d5 in
the future but okay night night g7 and
Bishop to c4 more if you continues
development we have castles and now
Knight to b5 again I'm going for this d6
squared
really block blacks development and now
if this was a more
a modern master or well yeah motor
master would go for d5 here he would
give up a pawn for active play for
example after each chapter Sun d5 now
you go Knight to a5 you attack the
bishop Knight captures Bishop captures
with check and after c3 now you go a six
push the knight back a3 now b5 Bishop to
b3 and now Queen to d6 blockading the
the passed pawn nice to the f5 is coming
attacking the bishop maybe ideas like h5
a black would get active play for the
price of one point but Paulson decides
for a6 first we have Knight to d6 now
and Bishop the c7 now hoping to get rid
of the knight this way not right away
first he wants to move the knight and
then get a double attack on the night
here with a for stopping b5 and now
Knight to g6 continuing development we
have Queen to d2 with the option of
still castling kingside
and Queen set both and now Queen to f6
developing the Queen while threatening
just to pick up the night and here at
morphine just defends that he could
Castle queenside but he plays rook to d1
instead saying that he will in fact
Castle kingside
with Knight to f4 and now as the g2
ponies under attack more female castles
King side and h5 now threatening h4 to
force this trade on f4 and here morphe
could decide to keep the tension with h4
but he decides to go for night
characters on c8 with stead instead in
the grab a pawn we have group characters
on c8 and now Queen captures on d7 so
morphe up upon and now Knight to d4 here
a Paulsen is is having some sneaky ideas
with some like rook maybe rook after the
8th maybe maybe sort of try and trap the
queen but morphe says nothing of the
sort works he plays Knight captures on
d4 and now e capture son d4 if you try
something like rook F here just just to
prepare the characters then morphe had
in mind just Bishop captures an f7 s
heels he's now temporarily up a piece so
he can give it back any way he wants and
after characters captures and captures
now we just go back and you are up to
pawns
so
great game for white so after Knight
captures on d4 Paulsen instead goes each
chapter Sundy for end now more if he
goes back Queen to f5 with a double
attack on the night and now forces a
queen trade as he's up upon Paulsen says
alright we have characters captures and
now Bishop to e5 just defending his d4
pawn and also having ideas of maybe d3
and picking up the be to pawn so Bishop
captures on f4 first by morphe Bishop
characters and now comes a rook captures
on d4 grabbing that pawn although other
other ideas were also possible yes the
bishop is under attack but maybe maybe
better with Bishop to d3
just block painting and then and then
figuring out what you're gonna do but
morphe decides for rook captures on d4
instead we have Bishop to b4 sorry
Bishop to e5 attacking the rook on d4
and now rook to e4 we have the sub
characters on b2 and now rook the b1 and
it seems like morphe saw one move
further than Paulsen as now if the
better moves the opponent b7 falls but
it is in fact it is in fact Paulson who
saw one move further than morphe so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best move for black here how do you
continue this without giving giving up
anything else while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that white definitely has some
background issues and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its rook
F to d8 now saying if you grab my Bishop
of course it's made its it's not me mate
right away as you could block with the
bishop the problem is if you capture
with rook captures here then first rook
captures on c4 and now there is the
threat of mate so you will not you will
not be able to capture the b7 point you
will first have to make some breathing
room for the king and also the rook here
is hanging so f3 pretty much the only
good move for white and now you capture
characters characters and you deal with
the the b7 point either by defending it
or by counter attacking white spawns so
that's the the best thing for you to do
here after rook F to d8 so rook F to be
8 and now what what can more
play more if you decided to go from g3
first and the now comes look to d4 this
is the important move now again
threatening to pick up the rook while
also in the rook moves you you will lose
the bishop now the bishop is attacked
twice so now if rook captures Bishop
captures again you don't have time to
pick up the pawn because the bishop is
hanging so after Bishop d3 now you play
b6
the point is nicely defended here and
everything everything is in order
so more if you went back Bishop to d3
and now rook captures on e4 by balls and
with Bishop captures on e4 and now rook
the c4 again with the counter-attack
going after the bishop and here at
Bishop captures on b7 just just going
after the pawn if Bishop to d3 just
attacking the rook then rook tabby for
defends the bishop and everything
everything is fine so instead Morphy
went for Bishop captures on b7 we have
rook captures and c2 now by Paulsen and
Bishop captures on e6 Murphy is now up
to pawns and he has a past a pawn but
Paulsen had everything planned out he
plays Bishop to d4 now with an attack on
the F do pawn and more fee has to decide
whether he wants to give it up as he
does have a double death pawn so maybe
it's not not a crime to give up the f2
pawn one way to go about it would be
Bishop to d3 now but instead and more if
you decided to the defender would work
to f1 but we do have to check Bishop to
d3 for example if Bishop to d3 then you
could capture with the rook and then
look the b4 saying that any any
discoveries will be met with rook
captures the bishop as a bishop is the
one delivering check so Bishop c5 you
would go rook to b8 with check King to
h7 and now
discovery doesn't really do anything you
can just block with the g6 but now look
the b5 again saying any discovery will
be met with rook captures so be sure
back to d4 rook the d5 an outburst of
the e3 and now finally King to h1
getting away from any discoveries f6
blocking now
f6 by white and now a5 you can continue
pushing and maybe maybe try and do
something with with this position but it
still will be very hard however more fee
instead of this decided to go for rook
to f1 he decided to defend it
and not to give anything up but now
Roque to pause and just puts the rug
behind the passport Bishop to b5
defending it and now came to h7 and here
it's very hard for four more feet to to
develop his pieces because you cannot
push a 4 and due to the pin
you cannot play King to g2 and then put
the F pawn because of this pin so you
cannot play King G to to h3 because then
you just lose the f2 pawn so it's not
easy so here more if you decided as a
pulse and played King to h7 to go Bishop
to c4 to trade the a 4 point for the f7
pawn and Paulson gladly grabs the D
passed pawn rook captures with Bishop
captures on f7 by morphe and now h4
wanting to further ruin Morpheus pawn
structure if captures here then yes
morph is up three points but those are
doubled pawns and that we have bishops
of opposite colors so Paulsen is very
confident that he will be able to hold
this so instead
kingi to by Murphy and rooked a 1 now
forcing a rook trade saying that I know
I know that this is a draw or is it but
okay Bishop to g6 check by morphic King
g8 and now trade you don't really have a
lot of other options we have capture
sunny one Bishop captures and it was in
fact in this position I'm all 36 that
morphe impulse and agreed to a draw
Morpheus up two points and he could he
could try to push for for more than a
draw but it is very unlikely as it is
objectively a draw so just just a throw
in a few moves that we could try let's
say g4 try to try to get some some some
moves in but then push up the d for not
allowing King h3 the pick of the DF b f2
pawn so let's say f3 now we're gonna go
Bishop e3 and if King h3 are gonna go
Bishop g5 and there's no way for the
points to ever cross the dark squares
and you're never touching this point
let's say King g2 you want to go with
the other way around King f8 you're
gonna go King if King give to working if
one doesn't really matter
you're gonna go let's say King f1 you're
gonna go h3 now getting hold of g2 and
now you're also going to grab hold of g3
so you will never be able to grab hold
of the point even Bishop f4 prevents it
and
attacks the point here King G one king
is seven now King f6 is coming and so on
so that way doesn't really work so
another another thing you could try for
example after G for Bishop to d4 again
with the same idea is maybe f4 by white
and then we get III you go after the
pawn king of three bishop g1 you play h3
okay all of your pawns except this one
are on light squares now which is fine
but then black starts bringing the King
into the game and now okay g5 King e7
and now you're gonna play King efore but
now bash up the c5 and again you don't
really have a way of of continuing to
push Bishop h5 Bishop a3 and you can
never get f6 in because if you touch a
five then just Bishop to b2 check pushes
the King back and if you try some sneaky
moves like f6 characters in g6 to try
and create a passed pawn black will say
not a problem King f8 we have king f5
and now Bishop to b2 just defending the
pawn here and there is not much you can
do here if you go after this point
Bishop c1 now says okay if you capture
it I'm gonna capture this guy
if f5 then Bishop g5 just holds and
there is no problem you can never cross
the dark squares but of course Paulson
knows this more more if you also knows
this and it was in this position hence
they agreed to a draw so game 5 yet
another draw but morph is still leading
by a margin of 1 point so the match
still going in his favor a person will
have will definitely have to do
something he's getting a lot of good
play with his Sicilian and Morphy not
still not not handling the Sicilian as
as well as he should have but we'll see
how it goes and maybe maybe in the next
game Murphy will finally stop being
frustrated for that loss in Game two and
maybe starts to produce some some ideas
that we are used to seeing from morphe
but we will have to wait for the next
game to see if that actually happens so
that's that's it for this game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Daniel hall back
Julio panel Uli Morris rosemary and
Sepik and matheus Jakob for a conversion
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos Aaron think of for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Murphy
saga and checking up
your wonderful suggestions and also I
just wanted to mention I I'm thinking of
making a video on maybe an opening or
something maybe not an entire video on
an opening maybe just a part of an
opening or something so do you have any
preferences on what opening you would
like to see I'm not going to go too much
into into depth just pretty much an
interesting ideas of the opening how to
approach it how to treat it and stuff
like that so if you would enjoy
something like that do share in the
comments section now what what kind you
would prefer so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day